Niko: Yaaaay
*clapping*
Sam: Its 4 Million Subs Eve
It was... It was a cold and dark september 2nd
All was well on 4 Million Subs Eve
Niko: Here is you guys
All 4 Million of you
Sam: All 4 Million
4 Million Subs Eve
Jake: The story of the Corridor Digital air conditioner started in 2011
In a loft, in Los Angeles, California
Where it was myself, Sam and Niko, and we were working, and it was 95ºF (35ºC)
We said, you know what? We don't have the money right now
We rather just go, and deal with it
And now, 5 years later, we finally decided to bite the bullet and pay for the air conditioning
And I gotta tell you, we were just out shooting today
It was super hot, and we get back, and its nice and cool in here
It is worth every penny
We learned a couple things from stress level zero
In the process of getting this air conditioning
Because the guy that we have over there...
Well... I don't gotta tell you guys
Wren: We have an issue, there is a pipe on the tool room that is leaking water all over the shelves
Jake: In our tool room?
Wren: Yes
Jake: How many AC units do you have to install
Were 2 out of the 3 leak water
We could just be dumping water somewhere
How is this OK? Now what do we do with these?
Now, we found a new guy, his name's Aswaldo
Aswaldo Marisco hooked it up he did a great job
He actually took the time and detail to do things properly on the roof
Even though you can't see that
That thing is pumping out, sweet sweet cool air
And our pump's not leaking because he took the time to get a bigger one and to put it in the wall
And it doesn't look too damn bad either
The future now it's bright at Corridor Digital, it's soo bright
I know this are first world problems OK?
Even without air conditioning we still got it made in the shade
But the point is: It's been a long journey
And we worked for it, and we worked for it, and we worked for it
There are 3 things that I will remember in my life time when I'm on my death bed
Number 1, the day that my kid it's gonna be born
Number 2, the day that I got married
And number 3, the day that we got air conditioning in Corridor Digital
Wren: And the day you met me!
Jake: And the day I met Wren